it is time for hatred that mail.
What is, hey, treat mail.
This is hatred mail.
We're getting to the oranges of this investigation.
So God bless.
You're not as shy.
[inaudible]
correct.
The tread mail written by patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because freedom
this week, Patriot mail introduces a new term.
We've talked a lot about impeachment on the
program as a possible means to remove Donald
Trump.
Although I don't believe that it will today
we are introducing a new term, take a listen
to this.
M Pritch mints will not get Trump out of office.
It will backfires spectacularly and propel
him to a landslide victory.
I can't believe David Pakman admitted to being
evil progressive's reveal in their navy vet
as though it's some kind of innocence.
Trump is behind you, David.
Feel the love.
Hello.
See what I did there.
I guess this long Coleman qualifies me as
unhedged.
You know, I have to say I agree with the hatred.
I don't believe that imprisonment is going
to remove Trump.
I just don't, don't see it happening.
And uh, I think we've got another urban dictionary
word that could maybe be added in with a definition
referencing the David Pakman show imprisonment.
I and all hatreds seem to be United.
We will not remove Donald Trump from the White
House with impeachment.
And I encourage you to pass the word along.
Make sure to fight hatred, autism by using
the coupon code hatred@fortywhenyousignupforamembershipatjoinpacmandotcomyougotowwwdotjoinpacman.com
you choose a monthly or a yearly membership
of your choice.
Doesn't matter which one you hit the red sign
up button.
And when you're offered the possibility of
inserting a coupon code you put in hatred
40 that's h, a, t, r, I, O, t, four zero hatred
at 40 your membership price will be instantly
dropped by 40% and hatred.
Nuts see this as a failing of their hatred.
CISM when people hear hatred, hate mail, and
instead of abandoning the David Pakman show,
they instead go to our website and sign up
with the coupon code.
Patriot 40 this is just so devastating for
hatred iots that I encourage all of you find
folks to do it.